das ist beschlossen das dritte
milliarden paket der bundesregierung das
paket das uns durch die teuer krise
bringen soll aber die begeisterung die
hält sich in grenzen denn es gibt
einfach zu viele fragezeichen
65 milliarden euro schwer klingt erst
einmal gut aber die kritik am paket die
ist laut mit der gießkanne verteilt viel
zu wenig konkret und vor allem wie soll
das ganze jetzt bitte schlussendlich
finanziert werden gucken wir uns mal die
einzelnen punkte an die er nun auch
ihren geldbeutel am ende entlasten
sollen wir sehen rentner sollen einen
zuschuss von einmalig 300 euro bekommen
studenten von einmalig 200 euro zudem
ein heizkostenzuschuss für
wohngeldempfänger
bei singles einmalig 415 euro gern auch
das kindergeld wird erhöht um 18 euro
monatlich und ebenfalls erhöht wird das
bürgergeld der nachfolger von hartz4 und
zwar um rund 50 euro im monat es hört
sich erst einmal nach vielen entlastung
an aber es gibt auch große kritikpunkte
zum beispiel die steuerfreie zahlung bis
zu 3000 euro netto für arbeitnehmer
eigentlich eine gute sache oder nicht
ganz denn die ampel koalition nimmt sich
bei dieser zahlung geschickt raus der
grund die entlastung soll von den
arbeitgebern gezahlt werden wann und ob
dieses geld gezahlt wird hängt aber ganz
von den arbeitgebern ab wenn die nicht
zahlen wollen geht der arbeitnehmer leer
aus und ob ein arbeitgeber in der
jetzigen krise seinen mitarbeitern solch
hohe summe aus eigener tasche zahlt das
ist fraglich ja das 65 milliarden euro
entlastungspaket eine unvorstellbare
summe und vor allem eine frage wie soll
das ganze finanziert werden zum beispiel
die strompreis bremse die uns
verbraucher vor hohen stromkosten
bewahren soll die idee der ampel die
gewinne der stromerzeuger die sollen
abgeschöpft werden die ampel spricht
hier von abschöpfung von zusatzgewinnen
eine schwammige aussage denn es ist ja
nun wieder klar wann und ab welcher
summe diese gewinne abgeschöpft werden
sollen auch wie viel geld dadurch
eingenommen wird weiß bislang noch kein
mensch zudem ist die rechtliche
machbarkeit völlig unklar und solche
gewinnabschöpfungen müssten ja
tatsächlich auf eu ebene geregelt werden
ja viele unklarheiten in einem paket das
uns alle betrifft und uns allen
eigentlich helfen soll durch den teuer
herz und den teuer winter zu kommen und
können darüber sprechen wir jetzt mit
bildpolitik chef jan schäfer bei uns im
studio schönen guten morgen ja wo ist
dieses milliarden paket die jetzt das
gros der große wurf der uns allen durch
den herbst und den winter helfen kann
also ich stelle mich ehrlicherweise
schon an diesem wort paket weil ein
paket immer bedeutet man bekommt irgend
etwas geschenkt und es ist ja gerade
auch schon in eurer moderation
angeklungen am ende bezahlen die meisten
von uns mit ein bisschen zeitverzug das
was jetzt ausgegeben wird ohnehin selbst
was kann man sagen dann ist es eher wie
eine blumenwiese da kann man sich sehr
sehr viel pflücken und es ist fast für
jeden etwas dabei für rentner etwas
dabei für studenten für hartz4 empfänger
auch für arbeitnehmer für unternehmen
das etwas dabei für gastronomen
beispielsweise also es wird werden viele
viele menschen bedacht mit dieser
blumenwiese aber und das ist ja auch
angeklungen es ist wie ein
gießkannenprinzip einfach ganz ganz
viele man hat versucht aus sicht von spd
grünen und fdp möglichst viele punkte
selbst durch zu bringen dann hat man
eben so ein sammelsurium an punkten wie
wir es jetzt genau sehen wie sicher ist
denn jetzt die finanzierung dieses 65
milliarden teuren pakets ich muss es
dann doch noch mal sagen es interessant
weil christian lindner und die fdp die
sind über gewinn steuer bisher vehement
abgelehnt haben und nichts anderes de
facto gibt es jetzt trotzdem und da
gehen die prognosen bisher auseinander
von einstelligen milliarden-bereich bis
deutlich weit zweistellig könnte also
bedeuten vielleicht sogar weit über 10
15 milliarden euro die man damit einem
da wäre ein teil der finanzierung wenn
man es auch mal so sagen kann dann schon
wieder in der kasse von christian
lindner man darf auch nicht vergessen
durch die inflation die wir sehen
bekommt christian lindner auch deutlich
höhere einnahmen über die sogenannte
mehrwertsteuer die umsatzsteuer also
wenn menschen einkaufen gehen zahlen sie
zurzeit ja höhere preise und damit auch
mehr geld an christian lindner über die
mehrwertsteuer das ist auch ein teil
dessen was er zusätzlich im paket hat
und damit finanzieren kann ganz klar und
es gibt wohl offenbar noch ein bisschen
spielraum auch im haushalt für das
nächste jahr von daher mache ich mir
über die finanzierung erst mal was das
angeht keine großen sorgen aber klar ist
alles was ausgegeben wird gerade wenn es
über schulden läuft
muss auch wieder eingenommen werden und
dann ist der steuerzahler am gefragt
betrifft also wieder die bürgerinnen und
bürger wie sieht es denn aus konnten
alle koalitionspartner ihre anliegen
durchbringen oder gibt es da auch
verlierer nach jetzigen stand muss man
sagen haben allem koalitionspartner mehr
oder weniger ein zwei große projekte die
ihnen ganz extrem am herzen lagen
durchgebracht beispielsweise die spd mit
ihrem bürgergeld die grünen mit ihrer
über gewinn steuer und die fdp mit dem
abbau der sogenannten kalten progression
immer interessant zu sehen wer dann doch
beim anderen umfeld aber ein punkt ist
zum beispiel ganz wichtig vieles ist ja
noch sehr unkonkret und beispielsweise
beim thema bürgergeld gehen die
erwartung von grünen und spd völlig
auseinander zu dem was die fdp
eigentlich möchte deswegen ist es auch
sehr unkonkret hier nur beschrieben und
da wird es noch sehr spannend sein ob
wirklich das bürgergeld was grüne und
spd wollen am ende auch so drin steht
oder ob es doch eher das wird was die
fdp will meine prognose ist nein da
werden sich spd und grüne durchsetzen
und die fdp muss klein beigeben
festzustellen hierbei auch dass es für
die aktuellen hartz 4 bezieher ungefähr
eine erhöhung um zehn prozent geben wird
des hartz-iv-satzes wir lassen das thema
miete und energiekosten heizkosten noch
mal raus aber einen tarifabschluss über
zehn prozent hat bisher kein normaler
arbeitnehmer gesehen und das ist aus
meiner sicht ehrlich gesagt unsozial
dass viele die hartz4 finanzieren mit
ihren abgaben ihren steuern weniger
gehaltsplus haben als die die jetzt vom
sozialstaat leben lasst uns gern noch
mal auf die arbeitnehmer schauen die
sollen ja eine einmalzahlung von 3000
euro bekommen die aber von den
arbeitgebern geleistet werden soll und
das ist auch eher auf freiwilliger basis
leaders aussehend über selbst oder von
ist einem ja eine motivation an
arbeitgebern arbeitnehmern einen
zusätzlichen bonus zu bezahlen wir haben
das in der korona krise ja auch schon
erlebt und es passt in die zeit wenn man
sagt wir steuern mutmaßlich auf eine
rezession zu viele unternehmen werden
gar nicht so viel geld zum verteilen
haben und jetzt ist die frage auch
gerade bei kleinen unternehmen ob die
sich das überhaupt dann lies genau das
ist natürlich richtig da gibt es
überhaupt keinen anspruch darauf aber es
gibt die möglichkeit der bundesregierung
zu sagen wenn ihr euren beschäftigten
einen bonus zahlen wollte den tarif den
lohn vielleicht nicht dauerhaft erhöhen
wollen weil gesagt ist es euch zu
unsicher liebe firmenchefs aber wenn ihr
sagt es gibt einen extrabonus dann kann
der bis zu 3000 euro hoch sein ohne dass
darauf steuern und abgaben anfallen also
da ist dann brutto gleich netto das
würde entsprechend bei einigen singles
beispielsweise fasst bis zu 6000 euro
dann ein bonus und das ist eigentlich
eine sache über die kann man sich
zumindest als arbeitnehmer wenn dieser
bonus dann gezeigt wird durchaus freuen
eine strompreis bremse ist angekündigt
dass der basispreis erst einmal gedeckt
ist für alle bürger mit gasheizung ich
muss mich dazu zählen gibt es das bis
dato noch nicht wir sind da die
aussichten was wird es dafür
lösungsansätze geben auch das ist ja
bisher sehr schwammig formuliert im
paket und alles was in diesem paket sage
ich es auch schon alles was auf dieser
blumen diese eher schwammig formuliert
ist bedeutet am ende das eigentlich die
bundesregierung noch nicht weiß in
welche richtung es geht das sehen wir
beim thema gaspreis bremse ganz genau
wir haben es bei anderen themen auf
dieser blumenwiese auch das bedeutet da
wird es noch viele debatten geben und
mutmaßlich ist er auch so schnell keine
lösung in sicht also viele fragezeichen
weiterhin bei diesem dritten
entlastungspaket
65 milliarden euro schwer vielen dank
jan schäfer
[Musik]